I'll score in verse my name is Pepe
welcome to Ooty TTD Jesus it's a tower
defense game no wait sorry it's an over
the top by a tower defense game it looks
amazingly fun
I'm really excited check it out they
also made me an illustration for me
which is a shocktopus that I'm
controlling with my bite hot-headed guy
sir
again look you're famous he doesn't care
the world is at peace it looks wonderful
the livelihood of honest soldiers are
under threat oh no we don't kill for
food but there's hope I'll thank God
the transdimensional rift your real
course Remagen okay we can different we
can preemptively defend Earth one ugly
alien at a time always bring protection
I always do alright so we have a new
hero an engineer we can shovel his name
Charley Shan Shan all right we have
Tripp McBain that's his name
I am I ready yes alright this looks cool
the enemy will soon take the road make
them pay for every inch oh hello
keep it protected lose your Bey or lose
your loser mission just like real life
there's our hero I dig the music yeah
yeah I'm honored doing it Roger
oh thanks games appreciate it oh no it's
sharks don't know there's baby robot
chucks anything about the paper robot
sharks ha ha ha alright so my job is to
send near the towers to it ok cool to
repair them there you go don't just
stand there you have enemies to destroy
where are they Oh God the baby sharks
they're coming
what they really weren't kidding when
they said over-the-top look at this
why do they have meat inside that kind
of freaks me out I wasn't saying whoa
double tower second upgrade in that's
cool awesome second Matt please oh crap
you're alive looks like the Greg in
accounts payable just won five bucks
thanks
so where are they gonna come from that's
bill at our amazing yeah here's the baby
sharks let's kill another one some of
them are passing Bay oh god they're huge
a pulse cannon what does I do Oh God not
the crabs the sniper crabs
come on I really like it so far it's
awesome alright let's upgrade that one
now we have sharks and sniper crabs look
at this freaking gorefest
can we at least cook them and eat them
or something I bet they're delicious
look at all the bullets oh my god oh god
that's the one Jane sniper clean I mean
Sue's metric crab of course Oh God we're
gonna make it shout it are we gonna make
it yeah we'll make it no problem [ __ ]
right guys beers on me Weir's on me oh
yeah could have done a better but hey
what are you gonna do I've got two new
heroes beautiful McGann horror dimension
located oh oh here we go
I like the art style I don't know where
they're gonna come from I got oh they're
gonna come from everywhere awesome
alright we'll set up one on you I don't
know what these do I guess I have to
take a chance
oh god there's a me why are we even here
if there's a me yeah okay they can throw
skulls that's cheating damage Oh God
look at all that weight yeah oh my god
they're everywhere
oh it's a Tesla coil laughing oh god
they're attacking this game is [ __ ]
sweet the music is awesome
blow it shoot him I mean more money cash
money Young Money [ __ ] oh cool we
have super abilities what it says oh I
just wasted it Wow Wow his abilities to
Arnold now this is what about yeah I
agree 100% a call the kitty Roger
goddamn damn bees they're everywhere I
don't have enough money I need more
money
yeah my god I did I thought that it was
that seriously the mission all right
level three let's do this on about we
have new hero is name is Felix hard
blast hell you yeah probably the best
here of all time let's be on it's my
voice all right yes sir
yeah ow oh nice there'll be heads now
amazing every game with big heads it's
the best game oh god they're coming I
can't move the music man I keep saying
it but it's awesome bye space crimes oh
god are they gonna come from here now
how do they even move on land
how and why do they look so happy I hope
a seashell but amazing others sushi
pieces in there I didn't realize haha
and we did it who are you gonna call
rudaba alright let's try something a
little bit harder oh no it's boss little
time oh my god oh god we all gotta hurry
up that one and then I won and god damn
it hurry up lads what the [ __ ] is that
ha ha oh my God we're so dead we're
doomed there's a giant flying shark
alright
all this time we thought sharks belong
to the ocean but if we were wrong oh how
wrong we were get it
use all the special attacks kill it you
need to kill this thing fast Oh God yeah
we did it thank God
oh that gave us a lot of money man okay
what do we got here
what if these whether they come from the
girl I really like these I don't even
know
what the [ __ ] is that that is awesome
what it's Oh My Goddess it's what I
think it's gonna happen happen oh my god
oh god we are dead it's the Kraken oh
sorry it said robot giant robot Kraken
holy [ __ ] what is going on oh god what
is that a tiny fish inside up oh my god
the future is dark and horrible guess
what the hell is that
my god it's so cute I just want to keep
it to look good oh it's really good
oh god there's so many release the
Kraken
I mean don't release the Kraken I
whatever it's all really
oh no they're wearing deaf skull face
now what is this call of duty Oh God
we're doomed
no way oh my minecraft man this is
ridiculous come on bras oh my
I don't think we're gonna make it pretty
sure we're not yep we're not gonna make
it
nah huh we were so close
hey at least I tried there it is
get up everyone more DPS more dots more
dots come on get the crackin don't it
distracted by its nice scent achill Oh
God look at those luscious lumps don't
you get distracted by tentacles what are
your Japanese women God get in sure
what happened
no ghost cables now I didn't pay
attention
I suck
I obviously suck at this game but let's
try another map
oh my god we're in the horror forest
again what is going on okay they're
gonna come from there what the hell is
that oh god don't tell me that's what I
think it is Oh God
it's a giant zambie shark what have we
done to deserve this
Oh God unleash everything there's two of
them are you serious oh my god you can't
I can't I know I died this game is
obviously too hardcore for me let's go
back to Boston I could play look it's a
red carpet all the celebrities are
coming oh my god they're all here Demi
Lovato Ashton Kutcher oh my god
well I didn't know prey and their crew
was gonna coat
this is amazing I got this flawless
tower defense tactics are never gonna
get passes in school they call me the
impenetrable mole that's a lie that has
called me ugly face oh my god anything
but the hipster monster ice what have we
done let's give this perfect it goes I
can't oh my god
best tower defense ever are they twins
are they just best friends hanging out
and just one day be like you know what
we should get glasses finally we did
something hey it's something this is a
really awesome tower defense game I I
think your brothers would like it as
well I live in link to it to check out
in the description and that's all for me
for now thanks for liking and commenting
on this video and thanks for hanging out
with me tonight Bros as always stay
awesome bros bro